Joshua Childress is a 37 year old father
of two who spent seven years as a U.S.
Border Patrol agent out of Arizona's
Yuma Station tracking footprints to
catch illegal crossers he resigned last
month after changing his mind about
illegal immigration.
I went in because I
have a background in the military it was
something I was good at, and it seemed
like something that needed done.
My understanding of the laws at the time
was that there were proper ways to get
into this country legally and that the
people that were coming across were just
shirking those laws
What is the border situation there?
Is there a fence or a wall?
What kind of obstacles are people trying to get around?
Most of our area does have
fencing infrastructure. There are parts
that have barriers that just will stop vehicles.
How did people get past that?
Oh, they would just climb over.
Would a wall
going across the entire border be useful
and stop people from coming over?
I don't think so it's been my experience that
whatever we do they find a way to adapt
and will adapt to that and then they
adapt to that. I mean it's a it seems to
be a pretty constant back and forth.
Border Patrol's policy of separating
parents and children crossing the
southern border sparked a national
outcry this summer which Childress says
underscores the impact the press and the
public can have on policy.
So there were separations under Obama.
No, it wasn't the the official policy to use it as
punishment.
Obviously Trump did try to use that
policy. It was pretty short-lived as we
saw it. When I left, the grounds for
separating anybody were more relaxed
than they were under Obama, so that's the
effect that the public outrage, I think,
has had, is that when the people just
won't tolerate it
it's going to have to change.
Were there
any particular experiences that made you
start second-guessing this
entire endeavor?
Not actually an incident
where I caught somebody, but after
they're caught they have to be processed
and I was assigned to processing one day
and as a routine part of the questioning
we have to ask
if they have scars or tattoos, and this guy
said he had scars and when he lifted up
his shirt to show me the scars there
were lash marks all over his back. When I
asked him what those were from he
explained that he refused to carry drugs
for a smuggler and they tied him up and
whipped him for it I didn't feel good
about sending that guy back and that was
a dramatic example but there's countless
others that didn't have a dramatic story
like that that they just want a better
life and I stopped being able to
reconcile that.
What also changed his
mind was listening to podcasts while
driving around the border 8 to 10 hours
a day. Specifically a show called
Unregistered, hosted by historian and
recent contributor Thaddeus Russell.
One particular episode featuring author and
sex worker
Maggie MacNeil made him reexamine his
fundamental beliefs.
And I've actually
had people go, "Oh yeah, I'm a whore!" - I'll go
"No no no, I mean an actual prostitute
as in actually take money for
sex" and then they'll be like "oh oh oh"
because they're thinking I mean slut
How did the ideas being
expressed there changed the way you
started to think about your job?
So there were two guests of Thad's that when I
first saw them I wasn't completely
thrilled. I didn't really want to hear
what they had to say, I thought, and one
of those is Maggie MacNeil and Conner
Habib who's a gay porn star. I don't have
anything morally against either those
lifestyles but I also didn't really want
to hear about it. But once I finally did
download and listen to those episodes, I
was blown away. I mean, they had so much
more to offer
and so much more to say than these
little categories that we put them in as
a pornstar or prostitute. They're
fascinating people: They're brave. They're
smart. They're heroic.
This small bias in my mind almost
stopped me from listening to these
people's stories and how much enrichment
I got from listening to their stories, so
then it made me start to take stock of
the rest of my life. If I had these
biases that I didn't really realize I
had, what else is there? How do I really?
feel about the drug war? How do I really
feel about prisons? And immigration
naturally came up as one of those
opinions.
And so what are your views about immigration now?
I think we're moving in the wrong direction. I think
we're moving towards more restriction
more enforcement and I think there
should be less. As Bryan Caplan, the
economist, says, if there's not a good
reason to keep you out, come on in. He
basically says that if there's no
communicable disease, no violent past,
there's no reason that you shouldn't be
allowed to come in and try to make a
life for yourself. I want to see a freer
world I want people to take charge of
their lives. I want people to be able to
make their own choices, and I don't want
an imaginary boundary to get in the way
of that. They're being spoken about as if
they are pieces to be moved around or
assets to be utilized. Like, no, they're people.
Deport all criminal aliens and
dismantle every last criminal gang and
cartel threatening our citizens.
We're told from the Trump administration that
the reason that we need to get tough on
the border is to stop, you know, ms-13
members from coming over, criminals,
violent criminals and drug traffickers
and child traffickers.
Those people do exist, and we do come across them, but
I no longer believe that immigration
policy or immigration restriction is the
solution.
If you have problems with
drug trafficking and violent gangs, which
are also linked to drugs most of the
time,
well let's legalize drugs in the United
States and that takes a significant
amount of power out of those guy's hands.
We can't fix the problem just by more
restriction.
Childress recently appeared on Russell's podcast for a long-form
discussion about his intellectual
journey and ultimate decision to leave
the Border Patrol.
He's now working on a maintenance crew
at an apartment complex alongside
several Mexican immigrants.
If what I have to say has any effect I hope that
it is that people will take inventory of
their life and take inventory of their
views. Think about why you believe what
you believe, and if you can go through it
and think, "yeah these beliefs are firmly
rooted," good. That's gonna help you sleep
at night that's gonna help you lead a
peaceful life, but if it's not I think
that's valuable information to have